.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Lauterbrunnen
ist wunderschön und idyllisch.
Im Volksmund
heisst es aber auch Tal des Todes,
weil an diesen steilen Felswänden
immer wieder
Menschen in den Tod stürzen,
die hier
eigentlich das Gegenteil suchen:
nämlich eine intensive Lebensfreude.
Risiko -
darum geht es in dieser Sendung.
Macht Risiko glücklich?
Was sind wir bereit,
für unser Glück aufs Spiel zu setzen?
Das möchte ich rausfinden.
Das hier ist Florian Zimmermann.
Freut mich.- Tschau.
Er wagt einiges für sein Glück.
Du stürzt dich nämlich
beim Basejumping
Hunderte von Metern in die Tiefe.
So ist es.
- Von wo springst du heute?
Du siehst die Nase dort vorne.
Wir gehen hinter die Nase
zu einer knapp 500 m hohen Wand.
Von dort springe ich heute runter.
- Flugwetter?
Wunderbar, ja.
- Gehen wir.- Gehen wir.
Wir werden noch
von einem Auto überfahren.
Das ist das grösste Risiko.
- Fast gefährlicher als das Springen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Wie viele Sprünge
hast du schon gemacht?
So um die 600.
- 600?
600 Basejumps
und ca. 470 Fallschirmsprünge.- Ja.
Der Weg ist jeweils
fast gefährlicher als der Sprung.
Sind wir ready?
- Es läuft.
Also, ich mache es noch mal schnell.
So, oder?- Ja, genau.
Geh hier durch damit,
dann kannst du ihn verstauen.
Wenn ich so gesichert sein muss,
ist es dort vorne richtig steil.
Da geht es runter, ja.
- Wirklich?
Ja, ja.
- Ja, logisch. Ich bin gesichert.
Noch nicht. Das kommt noch.
- Noch nicht?
Aber ...
- Du hast erst den Gurt an.
Wir binden dich noch an.
- Angurten.
Also, let's go.
- Let's go.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei. Das ist es?
- Das ist es.
Okay.
- Hier geht es runter.
Was für ein Gefühl hast du jetzt?
Keines, im Moment.
Also wirklich, im Moment ...
Du bist völlig entspannt?
- Jetzt noch, ja.
Und ... Also knapp vor dem Absprung
habe ich dann ...
... eine gewisse Konzentration.
Da gehe ich alles durch,
damit alles bereit ist.
Dann heisst es nur noch:
"Happy day."
"Happy ..."
- Ja.
Aber weisst du ... Was ist es,
das du im Basejumping suchst?
Grundsätzlich
ist es einfach ein Hobby,
in dem ich halt extrem viel ...
... Befriedigung fand
und das mir viel Ausgleich gab.
Es gibt mir auch eine gewisse ...
... langfristige Zufriedenheit,
weil ich immer wieder zurück auf ...
... gewisse Sprünge, Missionen oder
Erfahrungen mit Freunden schaue.
Ich habe ein langanhaltendes Glück
im Basejumping gefunden.
Ja.
- Es ist befriedigend.
Ich bin so nahe am Leben
wie wahrscheinlich wenige Menschen.
Du musst in dem Moment
so präsent sein ...
... dass alles andere um dich herum
verblasst.
Du lebst im Moment.
Gewisse Leute
finden das im Meditieren
und ich glaube, ich finde das
auf der Klippe einer Felswand.- Ja.
Nahe am Leben,
aber auch nahe am Gegenteil.
Das ist ein Wingsuit.
Oder was für ein Anzug ist das?
Das ist ein ...
Man nennt das Tracksuit.
Aber das ist
schon fast ein Hybrid ...
... denn er ist ziemlich gross.
Damit hat man
einen starken Gleitwinkel.
Der Unterschied zum Wingsuit ist,
dass ich keine Flügel habe.
Was ist wichtig beim Absprung?
An was musst du denken?
Nicht zu sterben.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Guten Flug.
- Merci vielmals.
Gut.
Hey.
- Guten Sp... Guten ... Gute ...
Guten Sprung.
- ... Heimfahrt.
Chest strap. Leg strap, leg strap.
Pilot chute.
Alright. Eins, zwei, drei.
- Oh mein ...
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Meine Güte, jetzt saust der da ...
Himmel Herrgott ...
* Lockere Musik *
* Jauchzer *
Sorry.
Ich war viel nervöser als er.
Der Moment, in dem er einfach ...
Hier geht es einfach
500 m in die Tiefe.
Ich kann mir leider sogar vorstellen,
warum das
so ein faszinierendes Gefühl ist.
Weil es zwischen dem ultimativen Kick
und dem ...
... ultimativen Wahnsinn ist.
Ich muss weg,
sonst wird es mir noch schwindlig.
* Lockere Musik *
Yeah.
* Lachen *
Fuck.
Hier hat es Gülle am Boden.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass alles nach Gülle stinkt.
Wie schnell warst du jetzt?
- Hey, verdammt schnell.
Verdammt schnell. Aber es war super.
Es war wirklich cool.
Es ist ein Sprung, den ich kenne.
Ich habe ihn schon viel gemacht.
Aber es ist immer wieder schön.
Gerade bei diesen Bedingungen.
Was will man mehr,
als durch die Luft zu fliegen?
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Ich weiss gar nicht,
wie ich auf der Bank sitzen soll.
Ist es ...
- Ihr könnt jederzeit stehen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe einen Buckel.
Ich bin ja schon froh, dass ich
dich an einem Stück am Tisch habe.
Ja, gut ...
Für mich war das nervenaufreibend.
Wirklich.
Wie ist so ein Sprung für dich?
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Wie gesagt,
so ein Sprung ist für mich sehr ...
Ja, einfach etwas sehr Normales.
Als würde jemand am Wochenende
Beachvolleyball spielen.
Ein Sprung hier in Lauterbrunnen
ist sehr locker für mich.
Von Basejumpern sagen viele,
das seien Spinner.
Man fordere das Schicksal heraus,
man werfe sein Leben weg.
Die Chance ist doch hoch,
dass du over and out bist,
wenn etwas passiert.
- Aber wie vielen passiert das?
Die Quote ...
- Hier passierte das schon vielen.
Du hast selber einen Freund ...
Ich habe ein paar Freunde verloren.
Meine ersten drei Freunde verlor ich
bei Auto- und Motorradunfällen.
Du fühlst dich nicht als Spinner.
- Ich bin sicher nicht ganz normal.
Aber ich bin ja nicht ...
Ich gehe nicht ohne Plan ...
... an eine Klippe
und springe runter.
Es gibt eine Vorbereitung,
ich habe mein Wissen
und jahrelanges Training.
Bis ich Basejumpen konnte ...
... machte ich
vier Jahre Fallschirmsprünge.
Dann dachte ich an Basejumping.
Ich sprang 500-mal
aus einem Flugzeug,
bevor mir die Idee kam,
von einem Felsen zu springen.
Wenn man das erste Mal
dort oben steht und weiss,
dass man jetzt
über eine Grenze hinausgeht ...
Der ganze Körper
sagt anfangs natürlich:
"Das machst du nicht."
- Das ist die Todesangst.
Und dein Kopf sagt: "Ich mache das."
Dann machst du den Schritt
und denkst: "Woah, ich mache es."
Die ersten drei Sekunden,
in denen du so bist,
sind unvergesslich.
Das ist etwas ...
Das hat mich von Anfang an ...
Es ist einfach ... Wow!
Unbeschreiblich.
- Macht es süchtig?
Du hast dieses Leuchten, das ich
bei anderen schon gesehen habe.
Schlussendlich wahrscheinlich schon.
Also ... Du hast ja danach auch
einen Dopaminausstoss und all das.
Das macht sicher süchtig.
Glückshormone machen süchtig.
Aber es gibt mir v.a.
eine Ausgeglichenheit.
Sodass ich
mein anderes Leben leben kann.
Das ist mein ...
Dort hole ich mir meine Freiheit,
meine Energie und meine Ruhe.
Lohnt es sich,
dieses Risiko einzugehen ...
... für das Glück,
das du dabei erhältst?
100%ig. Für mich 100%ig.
- Ja.
Es ist natürlich so,
dass die Risikoentscheidungen,
die wir treffen,
nie nur uns selber betreffen,
sondern immer auch andere Leute.
Und dass das so ist,
hat die Filmemacherin Mirjam von Arx
mit voller Wucht erlebt.
Sie hatte sich frisch verliebt
und erhielt kurz darauf
eine Krebsdiagnose.
Dann machte ihr Freund
hier in Lauterbrunnen einen Basejump
und verlor bei dem Sprung sein Leben.
Diese traumatische Erfahrung
hat Mirjam von Arx
in einem Film festgehalten.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
* Jauchzer *
Das ist mein Lieblingsvideo
von Herbert.
Er ist voller Tatendrang
und Lebenslust.
Wir haben uns über eine Partnerver-
mittlung im Internet kennengelernt.
Am Tag nach unserem Date ist Herbert
mit seinem besten Freund verabredet.
Andi - er ist Ausbildner
bei der deutschen Polizei.
Die beiden haben sich beim
Fallschirmspringen kennengelernt
und trainieren
so oft wie möglich zusammen.
Meine Ärztin hat mich heute
in ihre Praxis beordert
und hat mir mitgeteilt, dass ich
einen Tumor in der Brust habe.
Krebs.
Scheisse.
Ich möchte auf keinen Fall,
dass du dich in irgendeiner Weise
verpflichtet fühlst.
Ich habe auch nicht vor,
bald zu sterben.
Der Termin für die Operation
steht jetzt fest.
Sie wird bereits
nächste Woche stattfinden.
Dann Chemo, dann Bestrahlung.
Das Jahr kann ich abschreiben.
Nur wenige Leute
wissen von meiner Krankheit.
Sogar für uns beide
ist sie zur Nebensache geworden.
Herberts jungenhafte Begeisterung
gibt mir Energie
und seine Liebe
eine langersehnte Sicherheit.
Was mir Herbert nicht erzählt hat:
Er ist total fasziniert
vom Basespringen.
Sein Fallschirmkamerad Andi
hat bereits 99 Sprünge absolviert.
Das wird unscharf sein.
- Ach, das geht so. Am Weg sitzend.
Das sind Aufnahmen
von Herberts erstem Sprung hier.
Den Fallschirm
hat er sich von Andi ausgeliehen.
Ich werde dir zu keinem Zeitpunkt
sagen: "Spring jetzt!"
* Dumpfes Herzklopfen *
Bist du sicher? Was denn?
Ich würde mir
das einfach eingestehen.
Das ist ganz normal.
Ich meine,
Angst in der Situation ...
* Dumpfes Herzklopfen *
Ready, set, go.
- Jawohl.
* Jauchzer *
Ich habe gerade die erste Hälfte
der Chemotherapie überstanden
und lasse mir eine Tätowierung auf
meinen kahlen Hinterkopf stechen.
Sie bedeutet: "vorankommen",
"sich vorwärtsbewegen".
Dann kam ein Anruf auf mein Handy
und Andi war dran.
Er sagte: "Es tut mir leid,
ich muss dir etwas Schlimmes sagen."
Ich habe sofort gefragt:
"Ist Herbert okay?"
Und er sagte:
"Nein, er ist tot."
Ich wollte nur noch weg.
Ich wollte so schnell wie möglich
nach Interlaken ins Spital,
wo er lag und wollte ...
Ich wollte ihn sehen.
Ich freute mich im ersten Augenblick
für eine Zehntelsekunde,
weil ich Herbert sah.
Dann sah ich,
dass er in einem Zinksarg lag
und sich nicht bewegte.
Da ist eine Welt zusammengebrochen.
Ich ging dann näher ran.
Das Erste, das ich ihm sagte, war:
"Du Idiot."
Ich habe gesagt: "Du Idiot."
Er hat alles kaputtgemacht.
Er hat alles zerstört.
Er hat unsere Zukunft zerstört.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
* Orgelklänge *
Drei Monate
nach unserer ersten Begegnung
fahre ich zu Herberts Beerdigung.
Erst hier
lerne ich seine Eltern kennen.
Sie und Andi
sind nun meine einzige Hoffnung,
Antworten auf meine Fragen
zu bekommen.
Was hat ihn bloss angetrieben?
Die Eltern wussten nicht,
dass Herbert ein Basespringer war
und baten mich, alles
aus seiner Wohnung zu entfernen,
was mit dem Fallschirmsport
zu tun hat.
Ich war erst zweimal hier.
Oh.
Ja. Das Logbuch.
"Erster Sprung:
20.6., Lauterbrunnen".
"Ueli Gedächtnissprung,
stabiler Exit: zu früh gezogen".
In Klammern: "nach 4 Sek.".
"Schräge Schirmöffnung".
"In die Wand gedreht und berührt".
In Klammern:
"verdammt hart" - Ausrufezeichen.
"Ausser blauen Flecken alles gut".
"Schirm mit Loch" -
zwei Ausrufezeichen.
Er hätte schon vorher
tot sein können.
Jetzt geht es.
Alle drei Wochen
muss ich zur Behandlung.
Ich bin wütend.
Während ich um mein Leben kämpfe,
hat er seines einfach weggeworfen.
* Dumpfes Herzklopfen *
Langsam schwindet meine Wut.
Umso stärker wächst die Trauer.
Um Herbert und um das,
was nie sein konnte.
Mir bleibt
ein einziges Bild von uns beiden ...
... unzählige SMS ...
... und eine Abschiedsnotiz
am Kühlschrank.
Seit Herberts Tod
sind zwei Jahre vergangen.
Noch einmal bin ich
zum Memorial hochgestiegen,
um endgültig Abschied zu nehmen.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen,
jeden Tag so zu leben,
als ob es der letzte wäre.
Und nochmals
einen Neustart zu wagen.
Ich habe einen Mann kennengelernt,
mit dem ich mir eine gemeinsame
Zukunft vorstellen kann.
* Entspannte Musik *
# Walk down Portobello road
to the sound of reggae.
# I'm alive.
# The age of gold,
yes, the age, the age ...
Gemeinsam mit diesem Mann
hat Mirjam von Arx eine Familie
gegründet und zwei Kinder bekommen.
Die mittlerweile 55-Jährige
macht weiterhin Filme.
In ihrem jüngsten Werk "The Scent
of Fear - der Geruch von Angst"
geht die Filmemacherin
der Angst auf den Grund.
# I'm alive.
# I'm alive
and muito vivo, vivo, vivo,
# feel the sound of music
banging in my belly.
Mirjam von Arx ist jetzt bei mir.
Du stehst
an einem ganz anderen Punkt im Leben.
Klar, du bist zweifache Mutter.
Aber wie fest
hat dich Herberts Tod geprägt?
Immens.
Das hat mich total verändert.
Nicht nur sein Tod,
sondern auch die Reise,
auf die ich mich begeben habe,
um herauszufinden, was passiert ist.
Ich kam nach Lauterbrunnen zurück,
weil ich
total vor den Kopf gestossen war.
Es klingt absurd,
aber ich musste seine Leiche sehen,
um zu verstehen,
dass er wirklich tot war.
Und auch um mit dieser Wut
umzugehen, die ich hatte.
Dadurch habe ich
viel Zeit hier verbracht.
Einfach um herauszufinden,
was passiert war.
Ich merkte, dass ich erst
anfangen konnte zu trauern,
wenn ich mich durch diese Wut
durchgearbeitet hatte.
Du warst richtig wütend.
Was hat dich so wütend gemacht?
Ich fühlte mich betrogen.
Wir hatten uns gerade kennengelernt.
Wir hatten uns
in der Woche verliebt,
als ich meine Krebsdiagnose erhielt.
Dadurch, ähm ...
... intensiviert sich
natürlich alles.
Wir sagten nicht: "Ich finde dich
ganz cool, schauen wir mal."
"Daten wir mal und sprechen in
ein paar Monaten noch mal darüber."
Es war: "Entweder wir sind zusammen
und sonst stimmt es nicht."
Es hat alles
wahnsinnig intensiviert.
Dann machten wir Pläne.
In der kurzen Zeit,
in der wir zusammen waren,
fanden wir, das sei es.
Wir wollten heiraten.
Dann geht er da hin und stirbt.
Warst du wütend, dass er nicht für
dich auf den Sprung verzichtet hatte?
Es ging dir damals ja schlecht.
- Nein, das nicht.
Er tat sich extrem schwer damit,
mir überhaupt zu sagen,
dass er Basejumping macht.
Ich wusste das anfangs nicht.
Er sagte,
er mache Fallschirmspringen und so.
Als er mich nach meiner Krebs-
operation im Spital besuchte ...
... druckste er so rum
und sagte irgendwann,
er müsse mir etwas sagen:
"Ich mache auch Basejumping."
Nur schon, weil er es so anging,
war mir klar,
dass das für ihn extrem wichtig war.
Und dass er extrem Angst hatte ...
... dass ich das
schwer akzeptieren könnte.
Für mich war klar, dass man
niemandem etwas verbieten konnte,
das die Person machen will.
Das würde die Beziehung
nicht überleben.
Überlegst du, was mit deinen Eltern
oder deiner Freundin passieren würde,
wenn du verunglücken würdest?
Der Unterschied
zwischen Mirjam und mir ist ...
... dass ich
extrem offen und direkt bin.
Sie hat ja gerade gesagt,
dass er ungern darüber sprach.
Ich kenne viele, bei denen
nicht einmal die Eltern wissen,
dass sie Basejumping machen.
Ich bin wirklich ...
Everything's on the table.
Es ist extrem wichtig ...
... dass man klar kommuniziert.
Wenn mich jemand kennenlernt,
lernt er mich damit kennen.
Konkret: Du würdest das nicht
für deine Freundin oder deine Eltern
aufgeben, weil du merkst,
dass es sie zu stark belastet?
Nein. Nein. Ich würde so ...
... mein Glück
hinter ihrem anstellen.
Und das fände ich unfair ...
... gegenüber mir und ihnen.
Ja.
Du bist zweifache Mutter.
Dein Mann, der Vater deiner Kinder,
ist an einem Hirntumor gestorben.
Wir haben gesagt,
wir würden das nicht vertiefen.
Trotzdem spürt man da,
dass sich zu verlieben ...
Also,
Liebe ist ein sehr grosses Risiko.
Das hast du jetzt zweimal erfahren.
Ja, das ist es. Jedes Risiko ...
... birgt Chancen und Gefahren.
Bei diesen Dingen fokussiert man
sich auf die Chancen.
Wir hatten acht wunderbare Jahre.
Ich würde nichts anders machen.
Es war ... Es war ... Äh ...
Es war die schönste Zeit
in meinem Leben für mich.
Ich würde das nicht ändern,
selbst im Wissen, wie es ausgeht.
Ein Risiko bleibt.
Aber wenn man sich verliebt,
hat man ja ähnliche Symptome,
wie wenn du springst,
nehme ich an.
Man hat das Gefühl,
man könne die Welt verändern,
man könne Steine bewegen
und Felsen verschieben.
Das gibt einen unglaublichen Kick,
der eben nicht ...
... nur in der halben Stunde danach
mitschwingt.
Man hat wirklich das Gefühl, man
könne alles machen, was man will.
Gibt es Risiken im Leben,
bei denen du sagst:
"Das würde ich nie machen."
Ähm ...
Alles, was sportlich ist,
damit habe ich keine Mühe.
Bei mir ist es eher ...
... das Persönliche.
Dass ich mich jemandem hergebe.
Dass ich wirklich
alle meine Gefühle zeige.
Es geht in die Richtung.
Das macht mir Angst:
von einer Person verletzt zu werden,
die man extrem mag.
Das ist der Teil des Lebens ...
... in dem ich
eher etwas ängstlich bin.
In deinem letzten Film
geht es um Angst.
Um Leute, die sich überwinden
und ein Risiko eingehen.
Warum ist es für uns alle wichtig,
Risiken einzugehen?
Angst
ist grundsätzlich extrem wichtig.
Wer keine Angst hat,
lebt nicht lange.
Angst rettet einem das Leben.
Das ist auch ein bisschen das ...
... was ich
mit dem Film rüberbringen wollte.
Es geht darum,
die Angst vor der Angst zu nehmen.
Angst ist etwas extrem Wichtiges.
Und Risiken ...
Was damit verbunden ist:
Ohne Leute, die Risiken eingehen,
wären wir nicht weit über
die Pfahlbauer:innen rausgekommen.
Oder nicht einmal so weit.
Es ist das,
was die Menschheit vorwärtsbringt
und uns auch am Leben behält.
Was ist das Risiko, wenn man
im Leben kein Risiko eingeht?
Was passiert dann?
Man lebt einfach
nicht wirklich richtig.
Wenn du nie
Risiken eingehen willst ...
... wirst du nie ...
... deinen Charakter bilden können.
Angst formt deinen Charakter.
Du lernst, wer du bist,
indem du dich Situationen stellst,
die dir Angst machen.
Anscheinend
brauche ich viel Charakterbildung,
weil ich Basejumping machen muss.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich.
- So sehe ich das.
Vielen Dank für dieses Gespräch.
Und dieser Kick,
diese Anziehungskraft von Risiken,
ist faszinierend.
An was liegt das?
No risk, no fun. Wer wagt, gewinnt.
Das möchte ich
mit unserer Philosophin
und meiner "Sternstunde"-Kollegin
Barbara Bleisch genauer betrachten.
Barbara Bleisch,
Florian Zimmermann, der Basejumper,
sagte mir, dass er dem Leben
bei jedem Sprung so nahe wie nie sei,
obwohl das Todesrisiko ja eigentlich
immer im Gepäck mitfliegt.
Kannst du das nachvollziehen?
Wirklich nachvollziehen eh nicht,
weil ich es noch nie gemacht habe.
Ganz generell ist es wichtig,
sich Gedanken
über die eigene Sterblichkeit,
dieses Ende, das wir mit uns tragen,
zu machen.
Das ist
eine grundphilosophische Haltung.
Aber um das zu spüren,
muss man nicht das eigene Leben
immer wieder aufs Spiel setzen.
Diese Suche nach dem Kick,
also auch das Risiko
relativ weit auszuloten,
scheint mir ein Phänomen
unserer Zeit zu sein.
Oder gab es das schon immer?
Wir müssen schauen,
was der Kick genau ist.
Diese Intensität,
das Leben auskosten zu wollen,
ist wirklich ein bisschen
die Währung unserer Zeit.
Das Leben muss intensiv sein.
Das Schlimmste, das passieren kann,
ist als halb depressiver Schlufi
durchs Leben zu wackeln.
Man muss etwas erreichen,
etwas aus sich machen.
Das soll intensiv sein
und man will das auskosten.
Es könnte aber auch sein -
und das gab es schon immer -,
dass diese Sehnsucht,
an die eigenen Grenzen zu kommen,
mit der Sehnsucht nach einer Ekstase
verbunden ist.
Ekstase heisst nichts anderes,
als ausser sich zu stehen.
Ex stare -
auf Lateinisch "ausser sich stehen".
Indem man ausser sich steht,
hat man die Hoffnung,
etwas von dem zu erhaschen, was
jenseits unseres Bewusstseins liegt.
Das grösser ist als wir selber?
- Irgendwie das Gefühl zu haben,
es gäbe noch anderes,
das sonst verborgen bleibt.
Viele erzählen das
von extremen Erfahrungen.
Seien das Sprünge
oder Extremsportarten,
extrem lange joggen gehen
oder auf Berge klettern.
Da hat man das Gefühl, neue Formen
des Bewusstseins zu erlangen.
Aber generell:
Macht Risiko glücklich?
Es kommt darauf an,
wie es rauskommt.
Es ist interessant:
Wenn das Risiko sich auszahlt,
wenn es geglückt ist,
spricht man von Glück oder Chance.
Geht es in die Hose,
dann war es vielleicht auch Pech.
Dann schauen wir
auch anders darauf zurück.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf diesem Campingplatz
treffe ich eine Person,
die alles auf eine Karte gesetzt hat,
um ihren Traum zu realisieren
und ihren zweiten Lebensabschnitt
irgendwo friedlich
am Meer verbringen zu können.
Den Traum Auswandern haben viele.
Aber es sind dann doch eher wenige,
die sich auch trauen.
Roland Tschopp gehört dazu.
Hallo.
- Das ist der Richtige.
Ich bin Roli.
- Mona. Duzen wir uns?
Natürlich. Das ist einfacher.
- Baust du gerade um?
Oder was machst du?
- Ich baue ein bisschen um.
D.h., ich mache
eine Aussenisolation drauf,
damit es im Winter angenehmer ist.
Machst du das alles selber?
- Wenn ich Zeit und Geld habe.
Ich stelle mir vor ...
Campingplätze
kenne ich nur aus den Ferien.
Wie ist es, wenn man immer hier lebt?
Anfangs
war es schon eine Umstellung.
Man hat weniger Platz.
Aber ich habe Kanalisation, eine
Waschmaschine - eigentlich alles.
Du musst nicht
in die Gemeinschaftsdusche?- Nein.
Die Kanalisation
war die Voraussetzung.
Sonst wäre ich
nicht hierhergekommen.
Ein bisschen Privatsphäre
möchte ich schon.
Aber zu reduzieren, dich einzu-
schränken, wenig Platz zu haben -
geht das gut?
- Das ist kein Problem.
Darf ich es mir ansehen?
- Ja.
Wir können rein. Darf ich voraus?
- Sehr gerne.
Das ist mein kleines Reich.
Vom Platz her ist es nicht gross.
Aber ich habe einen Kühlschrank,
eine Tiefkühltruhe,
eine Abwaschmaschine ...
Geh nur rein.
Das ist das Schlafzimmer.
Du schläfst hier?
- Ich habe noch keine Matratze.
Ich brauche erst Geld.
Das Holz und alles, was ich
in den Umbau gesteckt habe ...
Ich schlafe momentan
auf der Polstergruppe.
Aber das sollte aufhören.
Es ist bequem.
Du schläfst auf der Couch?
- Ja.
Weil du dir
keine Matratze leisten kannst?
Ja. Ich setze im Moment
andere Prioritäten.
Das ist die Toilette.
Hier möchte ich von der Gestaltung
her etwas anderes machen,
um etwas mehr Platz
in der Toilette usw. zu haben.
Wie es dazu kam,
dass ich dich in Läufelfingen treffe
und eben nicht ...
... am Meer auf der Krim,
hat unser Reporter Christof Franzen
begleitet.
Wäre alles nach Wunsch verlaufen,
wäre Roland Tschopp
jetzt hier am Strand.
Gemeinsam mit seiner Frau Karyna,
die ursprünglich
von der Halbinsel Krim stammt.
Die Krim ist mir ans Herz gewachsen.
Ich fühle mich dort sehr wohl.
Ich habe dort eine Chance gesehen.
Das Leben auf dem Campingplatz
in Läufelfingen
war ursprünglich
nur als Übergangslösung gedacht.
Der Baselbieter
setzte alles auf eine Karte,
verkaufte seine Wohnung,
seine Metallbaufirma
und gründete eine neue:
Tschopps Krimreise.
Ehefrau Karyna packt die Koffer
für die bevorstehende Abreise.
Vor sieben Jahren
haben sie und Roland
sich im Internet kennengelernt
und später geheiratet.
Für Roland Tschopp ist das Haus
auf der Krim eine Flucht nach vorne.
Nach einem Herzinfarkt
und einem Burn-out ist er überzeugt,
dass er auf der Krim
ein längeres Leben vor sich hat
als in der Schweiz.
Das Ziel von Karyna und Roland:
ein Touristenort im Westen der Krim.
Seit der Annexion
der ukrainischen Halbinsel
durch Russland vor sechs Jahren,
kommen hier grösstenteils
nur noch russische Gäste her.
Westliche und ukrainische
Besucher:innen sind selten geworden.
Eine Folge
der internationalen Sanktionen.
Bis ihr neues Zuhause auf der Krim
fertig ist,
haben die Tschopps
eine Wohnung gemietet.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Am Anfang
überwiegen Tatendrang und Zuversicht.
Die Baustelle der Tschopps
liegt etwas ausserhalb der Stadt,
rund 2 km vom Meer entfernt.
Seit Herbst 2017 bauen sie hier.
Geplant sind eine Wohnung für sich
und vier Ferienappartements
zum Vermieten.
Wie läuft es?
Das Problem sind die Leute.
- Hat es zu wenige?
Zu wenig gute. Zu wenig gute.
- Aha.
Auf nächstes Jahr vermieten
wird nicht gehen.
Das wäre für den nächsten Sommer
vorgesehen gewesen.
Ja. Dafür reicht es nicht.
Wir müssen das Dach noch einmal
machen. Die haben Mist gebaut.
Aber irgendwann
wird das mein Domizil sein.
Mal schauen, wie Karyna mitmacht,
also wann sie kommen will.
Will sie in der Schweiz bleiben?
- Ja.
Karyna
ist noch nicht davon überzeugt,
wieder in ihre ehemalige Heimat Krim
zu ziehen.
Sie hat im Baselbiet
einen Teilzeitjob
als Pflegehelferin bei der Spitex.
Den will sie nicht aufgeben.
Aber wenn sie auf der Krim ist,
übernimmt sie aufgrund ihrer Sprach-
kenntnisse viel von der Organisation.
Dennoch: Die Probleme häufen sich.
Fehlende Arbeitsbewilligungen,
vergessen gegangene Genehmigungen
und Streit mit der Nachbarin.
Fünfzehn Jahre hatte Roland Tschopp
nicht mehr geraucht.
Die ständigen Verzögerungen
sind nervenzehrend
und gehen an den Geldbeutel.
Der Traum vom ruhigen Leben
auf der Krim droht zu platzen.
Diese Wohnung ist gemacht,
diese auch, diese auch,
jetzt werden noch die zwei gemacht.
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Ukrainisch. *
Wenn ihr so macht,
seht ihr jedes Mal das Rohr.
Einfach damit ihr es wisst.
Aber ich halte mich raus.
Ich bin dann mal weg.
Macht es gut.
Ich möchte das so.
- Warum?
Ich diskutiere nicht.
- Was, diskutieren?
Es ist egal, ob hier oder hier.
- Nein.
Ich möchte es hier in der Mitte.
Oben ist der Hahn, unten
bei der Schublade die Anschlüsse.
Wenn man ein Problem hat,
kann man da noch etwas machen.
Hier ist es
hinter der Schublade versteckt.
Ich möchte das bitte hier.
Wie die anderen in der Mitte.
Basta. Okay?
Mhm.
- Ja?
Ja.
- Ja, ja. Sicher?
Gut.
Karynas Aufenthalte auf der Krim
sind meist kurz.
Im Baselbiet wartet ihre Arbeit.
Roland bleibt zurück.
Tschau, tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.
Der Bau
geht nur noch schleppend voran
und
verschlingt mehr Geld als erwartet.
Für den vollständigen Innenausbau
wird es nicht mehr reichen.
Sommer vor einem Jahr:
Roland Tschopp ist schon länger
wieder von der Krim zurück.
Ein schwieriges Jahr
liegt hinter ihm:
Die Baustelle ist aufgrund von Corona
stillgelegt worden,
seine Gesundheit
macht ihm erneut zu schaffen.
Doch das ist nicht alles.
Ja, es ist ...
... viel passiert in diesem Jahr.
Karyna ist nicht mehr bei mir.
Sie ist ausgezogen.
Auf eine Art ...
... verständlich.
Die zwei Jahre seit ...
... ich alles verkauft habe,
kamen noch Rheuma in den Händen,
Schmerzen usw. dazu.
Da war ich natürlich
nicht gerade der beste Ehemann.
Ich war oft gereizt
und war mieser Stimmung.
Und auf der Krim unten ...
Denkst du, das sei definitiv?
- Was?
Oder habt ihr euch
einfach mal getrennt?
Sie hat gesagt,
sie komme nicht zurück.
Ja.
Aber das Verhältnis,
das wir noch pflegen,
ist an und für sich gut.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Das Bauprojekt auf der Krim wollen
beide unbedingt zu Ende führen.
Es bleibt aber schwierig.
Geld ist fast keines mehr da.
Roland Tschopp
hat inzwischen Sozialhilfe beantragt.
Dennoch: Der Traum vom Haus auf der
Krim ist noch nicht ganz ausgeträumt.
* Ukrainische Volksmusik *
Deine letzten Worte in diesem Film
waren: "Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt."
Seither ist ein Jahr vergangen.
Wie steht es um die Hoffnung?
Die ist nach wie vor da.
Der Traum bzw. das Vorhaben
ist nicht gestorben.
Es ist sowieso
mit einem gewissen Risiko verbunden.
Ich halte daran fest
und Karyna auch.
Hast du es bereut, dass du
so viel Risiko eingegangen bist?
Auf keinen Fall.
Wo der Bau jetzt steht
und wie das Objekt aussieht ...
... das ist eigentlich okay.
Aber du bist jetzt hier auf
dem Campingplatz, quasi mittellos,
du hast
keine Matratze zum Schlafen ...
Ja ...
Ich glaube, ich bin ...
Ich kann mich ...
... in die Situation schicken.
Was hat die ganze Zeit
mit dir gemacht,
als du auf der Krim warst und dann
wieder zurückkommen musstest?
Wie ging es dir da?
Nicht so gut.
Mein ganzes Vermögen
steckt in diesem Bau.
Und du wusstest, dass du
alles in den Bau investiert hast.
Ja, das Risiko ...
Ich wollte nicht so viel einsetzen.
Es hat einfach Geld gekostet.
Ich konnte nicht mehr aufhören,
weil schon so viel drinsteckte.
Schlussendlich
war es doch nicht genug.
Was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Kämpfen.
Es geht weiter.
Das Gefühl ist nicht gut.
Aber es ist
auch kein Gefühl des Versagens.
Es ist ja nicht nur mein Fehler ...
... dass ich das Risiko eingegangen
bin und der Bau nicht fertig wurde.
Sondern die Umstände?
- Ja, die Umstände.
Ja.
Es hat ja auch eure Beziehung
so stark belastet,
dass ihr euch getrennt habt.
- Seit ...
... es mir besser geht,
ich wieder ein Jöbchen habe
und sehen kann, dass es
in zwei, drei Jahren fertig wird ...
... wurde auch die Stimmung besser.
Hast du Hoffnung auf eine Versöhnung?
Eigentlich sind wir zusammen.
Aber sie wird nie wieder
auf diesem Campingplatz wohnen.
Das muss ich akzeptieren.
Das ist eigentlich okay für mich.
Das ist okay.
Wenn man sich das anschaut,
hast du vieles aufs Spiel gesetzt:
deine Gesundheit, deine Beziehung,
du hast all dein Geld investiert ...
Alles für diesen einen Traum
eines Hauses auf der Krim.
Bist du zu viel Risiko eingegangen?
Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Es gibt sicher gewisse Durchhänger,
bei denen du dich fragst,
ob du das Richtige gemacht hast.
Aber ich habe das Richtige gemacht.
Für dich stimmt es also?
- Für mich stimmt es.
Für mich stimmt es.
Ich freue mich auf das, was kommt.
Ich drücke dir alle Daumen.
- Danke.
Ich hoffe, dein Optimismus
wird sich bewahrheiten.
Der wird sich bewahrheiten.
Es stösst noch eine Person zu uns.
Ghamkin Saleh ist auch viel Risiko
eingegangen in seinem Leben:
Es nimmt mich wunder, ob sich seine
Risikobereitschaft ausgezahlt hat.
Ghamkin Saleh kehrt zurück
an den Ort, wo seine Karriere begann.
Das Santa Lucia war
mein erstes Leben in der Schweiz.
Ich habe fast alles gemacht.
Ich habe dort auch Musik gespielt.
Ich machte den Abwasch,
servierte, machte Pizza,
schnitt dem Personal die Haare ...
Ich habe fast alles gemacht.
Vom Tellerwäscher
zum Multi-Unternehmer.
Das ist mein Nachbar,
das ist kein Problem.
Das ist mein erster Laden.
Hoi, Andi.
Mit dieser Filiale im Zürcher Kreis 5
legte Saleh vor rund 20 Jahren
den Grundstein
für sein Imperium
von Günstig-Coiffeursalons.
Als junger Mann flüchtete
er allein aus Syrien in die Schweiz.
Als Kurde gehört Saleh
in seiner Heimat zu einer Minderheit,
die vom Staat unterdrückt wurde.
Gerade mal drei Jahre in der Schweiz,
eröffnete er
bereits den ersten Salon.
Die Sprache, die Kultur, die Aufent-
haltsbewilligung in der Schweiz -
das war nicht einfach.
Aber alles ist möglich,
wenn man will und wenn man ...
... daran arbeitet.
Man kann sich die Wünsche erfüllen.
Mittlerweile
umfasst das Saleh-Imperium
zwei Restaurants
und zwölf Coiffeursalons.
Zur Filiale
im multikulturellen Zürcher Kreis 5
kamen im Laufe der Zeit Geschäfte in
der teuren Zürcher Innenstadt dazu.
Seine Motivation war stets,
die in Syrien zurückgebliebene Mutter
und Geschwister zu ernähren.
Unterdessen konnte er die Gross-
familie zu sich in die Schweiz holen.
Jeder seiner Brüder
führt ein eigenes Geschäft,
in diesem hier ist es der jüngste.
Wenn man sieht, dass jemand
den Willen und den Mut hat,
und er die Familie nicht schädigt,
lassen wir ihn machen.
Wie immer, Paul?
- Ja.
Nichts Spezielles?
- Keine Dauerwelle.
Keine Dauerwelle?
Machst du keine Werbung?
Augenbrauen schneiden?
- Keinen Kahlschnitt.
Filmemacher Paul Riniker
gehört zu Salehs Stammkund:innen.
Er ernährt einfach
seine ganze Sippe damit.
Das ist sein Ziel. Aber ich glaube
nicht, dass er reich werden will.
Ist das so?
100%ig.
Die Familie ist eine Stärke ...
... all dieser Geschäfte.
Aber auch eine Schwäche ...
- Es bindet dich.
Genau.
Mittagessen zusammen
mit einem seiner engsten Freunde.
Saleh hat eine beispiellose Karriere
als Coiffeurkönig gemacht,
sein eigentlicher Traum
bleibt ihm aber bis heute verwehrt.
Seit seiner Jugend will der
musisch begabte Saleh Filme machen.
Vor zwei Jahren begann er
mit den Arbeiten eines Roadmovies
und ist für den Dreh
extra mit einer Schweizer Filmcrew
in seine alte Heimat geflogen.
Die Finanzierung des Projekts
gestaltet sich allerdings schwierig.
Ich habe alles darauf gesetzt,
den Film fertigzumachen.
Ja, dann ist halt fertig.
Wir schaffen das.
Also alles: Energie, Geld ...
- Alles.
Wirklich alles: Energie, Geld ...
Ja, ich habe es einfach riskiert.
Hier im Zürcher Vorort Schlieren
lebt Ghamkin Saleh mit seiner Frau
und den beiden Töchtern.
Hallo.
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Arabisch. *
Es ist ein dreisprachiger Haushalt -
Salehs Frau Katarzyna
stammt ursprünglich aus Polen.
Mach mal. Helft Mami.
Helfen, helfen.
Man muss auch zu Hause
den Chef spielen.
Ghamkin und Katarzyna
haben sich vor gut 20 Jahren
in Zürich kennengelernt.
Er war in seinem Geschäft
in der Josefstrasse.
Er stand draussen und telefonierte
und sah uns dabei an.
Dann hat er gesagt:
"Gehen wir was trinken heute Abend."
Ich fand: "Okay, machen wir."
"Aber ich komme nicht alleine.
Ich nehme eine Freundin mit."
Dann haben wir uns langsam  ...
... kennengelernt.
Bei den Salehs herrscht
eine traditionelle Rollenverteilung.
Sie hält ihrem Mann den Rücken frei.
Sie ist super.
Sie mischt sich nicht ein.
Sie unterstützt mich.
Sie arbeitet hinter den Kulissen
mit aller Kraft mit.
Einfach so. Es ist wichtig,
keinen Druck zu haben.
Und dann kam die Pandemie.
Sämtliche Saleh-Betriebe
mussten coronabedingt schliessen.
Diese Bilder entstanden zwischen
der ersten und zweiten Welle.
Die Mietkosten aller Saleh-Betriebe
betragen über 100'000 Fr. monatlich.
Zusätzlich fehlen dem Unternehmer aus
der Zeit des Lockdowns die Einnahmen.
Er hat Zweifel, dass alle
seine Betriebe überleben werden.
Also ... Auf emotionaler Ebene
hoffe ich noch.
Aber praktisch gesehen ...
... glaube ich es nicht.
Bei den Geschäften
mit hohen Mietkosten ...
... müssen wir mit dem Besitzer
oder der Verwaltung verhandeln,
damit die Miete reduziert wird,
sonst müssen wir es aufgeben.
Das kann ich mir nicht leisten.
Das steht gerade wirklich im Raum?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
Saleh musste zwar infolge
keinen seiner Betriebe schliessen,
aber auch nur, weil er
seine finanziellen Reserven anzapft.
Geld, welches
für seinen Film vorgesehen war.
Mind. 50'000 Fr.
würde er für die Fertigstellung
seines Low-Budget-Projekts benötigen.
Ich kann mit dem Minimum leben.
Anstatt einer Vier-
eine Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung,
anstatt eines grossen Autos
ein kleines und einen Töff -
das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Die einzige Sorge, die ich habe:
Meine ganze Familie
sitzt in demselben Boot.
Aber sonst ...
Ich bin mit 1'000 Dollar
in die Schweiz gekommen.
Ich kann auch mit 1'000 Dollar
weggehen. Das ist kein Problem.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Hallo. Ich bin Mona Vetsch.
- Hallo zusammen.
Machen wir es modern.
- So?
Ich bin Roli.
- Hoi, Roli. Freut mich.
Das Erste,
was sich die Leute überlegen:
Ist das noch derselbe Mann,
den man im Film gesehen hat?
Ghamkin, du siehst ganz anders aus.
Was ist passiert?
- Ja, kreisrunder Haarausfall.
Der Coiffeur-König ohne Haare.
Das ist schon hart.
Alopecia totalis. Das wird durch das
Immunsystem und Stress ausgelöst.
Es ist eine Krankheit.
- Emotionaler Stress.
Hat das mit dem Stress
während Corona zu tun?
Ja, schon ... Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich hatte
einen kleinen Motorradunfall,
die Geschäfte gingen zu ...
Es war alles zusammen.
Zum Glück betraf es die Haare
und nicht das Herz oder so.
Aber ich bin gesund. Gott sei Dank.
Wir sprechen über Risiken.
Als du 20 warst,
gingst du ein grosses Risiko ein
und entschiedst dich dazu,
Syrien zu verlassen.
Du hast dein Glück
in der Fremde versucht.
Wovon träumtest du?
Was trieb dich dort an?
Weisst du ... Ich verglich mich ...
... vorher sofort mit Roland.
Es ist ...
Ich meine ... Für ihn ...
Für ihn war es viel schwieriger,
als es für mich war.
Warum?
- Ich hatte nichts zu verlieren.
Wundert es dich, dass Ghamkin sagt,
du seist mehr Risiko eingegangen,
weil du mehr zu verlieren hattest?
Ich denke das schon auch.
V.a. wegen des Sozialwesens,
Krankenwesens usw.
Wenn man einen Herzinfarkt hatte,
wie ich ...
Alles in der Schweiz aufzugeben
und etwas anderes anzufangen ...
Was war bei dir ...
... besonders schwierig
auf diesem Weg von Syrien,
bis du in der Schweiz richtig an-
gekommen bist und Fuss gefasst hast?
Ich hatte nichts zu verlieren.
Ich habe immer nach vorne geschaut.
Okay, anfangs hatte ich
mit der Sprache Mühe in der Schweiz.
Ich bin
ein kommunikativer, sozialer Mensch.
Ich bin auch ein Berührungsmensch.
Das war schwierig bei der Arbeit.
Ihr habt beide
das Schweizer Ideal gelebt:
Ihr wart selbstständig,
habt Geschäfte aufgebaut,
Arbeitsplätze geschaffen
und viel gearbeitet.
Das gilt ja als das Ideal.
Aber jetzt
zahlt ihr einen Preis dafür.
Du hattest Burn-outs
und einen Herzinfarkt.
Du trägst sehr viel Verantwortung,
das hast du gesagt.
Ich habe meine Haare verloren.
Selbstständig zu sein und so viel
zu arbeiten, ist auch ein Risiko.
Ihr habt
mit eurer Gesundheit dafür bezahlt.
Du bist ein Jahr älter. Fang du an.
Das kann man so sagen, oder?
War dir bewusst,
dass das ein Risiko ist?
Als ich damit anfing,
glaube ich nicht.
Es war mir nicht bewusst, was über
die Jahrzehnte auf mich zukommt.
Mit der Zeit natürlich schon.
Ich hatte Angestellte ...
... Geldschwierigkeiten,
ging Risiken mit dem Aufbau ein usw.
Ich habe eigentlich
immer gearbeitet.
Würdet ihr noch einmal
richtig viel Risiko eingehen?
Gibt es da etwas?
- Die Liebe für Roland.
Liebe ist immer das grösste Risiko.
Mein Risiko läuft ja noch.
Ein zweites Risiko bzw. noch einmal
ein Risiko auf mich zu nehmen,
möchte ich nicht mehr. Eines reicht.
Ich riskiere gerne.
Aber nicht mit meiner ganzen Familie
und meinem ganzen Vermögen.
Es war mein Traum,
sie irgendwie abzusichern.
Ich werde diese Sicherheit
nie riskieren, nein.
Für keinen Traum der Welt?
- Nein. Auch der Film: weg damit.
Aber dein Risiko: Chapeau für dich.
Das kann ich wirklich nicht machen.
Risiko ja, aber nicht ...
... wie er.
- ... mit alles.
Fast.
"Mit alles".
- Fast.
"Risiko mit alles".
Aber er ist stark. Weisst du, warum?
- Warum?
Wegen der Schweiz.
Er kann immer zurückkommen.
Das muss man schätzen.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Was Ghamkin Saleh
im Gespräch angedeutet hat, stimmt.
Wenn es schiefläuft, sind wir
in der Schweiz durch unser System
im schlimmsten Fall abgesichert, im
Gegensatz zu viele anderen Ländern.
Als würde das nicht reichen,
versichern wir uns noch
gegen fast jede Eventualität.
Z.B. gegen das Wetter, Löcher
in den Zähnen oder Schäden am Auto.
Niemand ist so gut versichert
wie wir, würde ich behaupten.
Wir haben alles und jedes
so geregelt,
damit möglichst nichts passiert.
Haben wir ein Problem mit Risiko
oder müssen wir es darum suchen,
weil es uns zu sicher ist?
Dass wir uns von Klippen stürzen,
weil wir zu versichert sind,
finde ich eine sehr steile These.
Wir machen nicht Basejumping, weil
wir zu oft Velohelme anziehen müssen?
Das ist eine Überstrapazierung.
Aber wir haben viele Versicherungen.
Wir haben zumindest
viele Möglichkeiten dazu.
Das gilt aber
für die meisten Industrienationen
bzw. wohlhabenden Länder.
Das führt dazu,
dass wir es gewohnt sind,
das Schicksal
in die Schranken weisen zu können.
Umso mehr macht es uns Mühe,
das Schicksal zu akzeptieren,
wenn es uns dazwischenfunkt, wenn es
nicht so läuft, wie wir wollen.
Oder wenn ein Sicherungssystem
trotzdem versagt.
Alles kontrollieren
können wir selbstverständlich nicht.
Unfälle gibt es halt immer noch.
* Erwartungsvolle Klänge *
Ich bin zurück in Lauterbrunnen.
Hier auf dem Friedhof
hat die Gemeinde seit Kurzem
eine Gedenkstätte
für alle Unglücksopfer eingerichtet.
Auch um zu zeigen,
dass diese Todesfälle nicht spurlos
an der Gemeinde vorbeigehen.
Die eigenen Grenzen auszuloten
und ins Extreme zu gehen,
hat Steven Mack
immer gemacht in seinem Leben.
Bis er einen schweren Unfall
beim Bungeejumping hatte
und dabei sein Augenlicht verlor.
Das hinderte ihn aber nicht daran,
immer wieder das Risiko zu suchen.
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Die Ganterbrücke bei Brig,
auf der Strecke zum Simplonpass,
150 m hoch.
Zwei Jahre
nach seinem verhängnisvollen Unfall
kehrt Steven Mack mit einem Freund
an den Unglücksort zurück.
Hier ist es ca. 120 oder 130 m hoch.
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
Man steht auf dieser Strebe,
macht den Schritt ins Leere
und springt runter in die Freiheit.
Ich sprang
aber nicht in die Freiheit,
sondern in die Handschellen.
Ich bin jetzt davon abhängig.
Ich habe nicht mehr so viel Freiheit
wie vorher.
Bereits zehnmal war Steven
von der Ganterbrücke gesprungen.
Beim elften Mal rissen die Seile.
Es geschah bei diesem Sprung.
Ich kam
nicht in die Pendelbewegung rein,
sondern fiel weiter Richtung Boden,
weil das Seil riss.
Ich schlug auf einer Lärche auf
und fiel dann auf einen Schuppen.
Und von dort aus auf den Boden.
Dann kam der Helikopter.
Mehrere Wochen lag Steven aufgrund
seiner schweren Verletzungen im Koma.
Ich hatte ca. 40 Brüche,
viele davon im Gesicht.
Der Fuss war auch verletzt.
Ein Gelenk ist jetzt versteift.
Ein paar Wirbel waren gebrochen,
das Schlüsselbein auch.
Ich hatte mir die Zunge abgebissen
und anfangs Mühe mit Sprechen.
Ein paar Hirnverletzungen
bzw. ein Schädelhirntrauma.
Und seither
habe ich das Augenlicht verloren.
Der 22-Jährige musste lernen,
mit dem Blindsein umzugehen
und sich in einer neuen Welt
zurechtzufinden.
Ich kannte den Weg ja schon.
Ich musste einfach lernen,
anders zu sehen.
Ich "sehe" jetzt Sachen,
die du nicht siehst.
Den Bodenbelag siehst du ja nicht.
Du orientierst dich am Visuellen,
an den Bäumen oder so.
Ich musste lernen,
das andere zu sehen,
z.B. eben den Asphaltbelag.
Mit dem Gehör.
Ich nehme wahr, dass es enger wurde,
wegen der Schrebergärten.
Ich sehe sie nicht,
aber ich höre, dass hier etwas ist.
Hier nehme ich
ein Gebüsch oder einen Baum wahr.
Ich höre von der Dichte her,
dass da etwas ist.
Stevens Leben bis dahin war das
Klettern, der Sport, die Freiheit.
Sein Ziel: Bergführer.
Eine Zukunft in der Natur,
in den Bergen.
Von einem Moment auf den andern
verlor Steven alles,
wofür er gelebt hatte.
Denkst du,
du kannst irgendwann wieder sehen?
Ja.
- Wieso?
Weil ich es will.
Die Augen sind nicht verletzt.
Ich bin durch das Trauma erblindet.
Anatomisch
sind meine Augen in Ordnung.
Alle Ärzte und Therapeuten
sagen mir ...
... dass ich physisch
eigentlich sehe.
Es liegt an mir -
seelisch, unterbewusst.
Ich will noch nicht sehen.
An dem arbeite ich. Das kommt.
Steven
versucht mit unzähligen Methoden,
das Trauma des Sturzes aufzuarbeiten.
Auch mit Akupunktur.
Zwei- bis dreimal in der Woche
trainiert er, um fit zu bleiben.
Diese Übung ist immer seine erste.
Sie ist ihm am wichtigsten,
weil er damit Kraft fürs Klettern
trainieren kann.
Klettern gibt mir halt viel
bzw. am meisten.
Wenn ich dort noch gut unterwegs bin
und andere beeindrucke ...
Warum ist es dir wichtig,
andere zu beeindrucken?
Weil ich mir
die Bestätigung holen muss,
dass ich doch noch etwas kann,
obwohl ich blind bin.
Es ist ein Ausgleich zwischen dem,
was ich kann und was nicht.
* Emotionale Rockballade *
# Es war ein langer, langer Weg
und niemand sagte: "Es wird leicht."
# Und es wird Zeit,
dass man ihn geht.
Heute geht es
mit Freunden zum Klettern.
Zur Galerie
oberhalb Weesen am Walensee.
Steven ist auch nach seinem Unfall
immer noch ein sehr guter Kletterer.
Wenn man in den Bergen zurechtkommt,
auf einen Viertausender geht,
muss man psychisch gut dran sein
und kämpfen können
und an oder
über seine Grenzen hinaus gehen.
Man muss stark sein
und den Willen haben.
Ich glaube, die Berge
haben mich ziemlich stark gemacht,
auch bezüglich des Unfalls.
Man kennt das aus den Bergen -
belastbar zu sein
und an die Grenzen zu kommen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Luki?
Kann ich da einen Kopfsprung machen?
Ja.
- Von hier oben?
Von dem Stein aus? Ja.
Ich zeige dir die Richtung.
Hier.
- Da rüber?
So, genau. Genau so.
- Muss ich weit springen?
Ne ... Ja, schon einen Meter.
Ja.
- Easy, passt schon.
# Nicht jeder kann ihn gehen.
# Es war ein langer, langer Weg
und niemand sagt ...
Trotz oder vielleicht sogar
wegen seiner Blindheit.
In den folgenden Jahren lotet Steven
immer wieder seine Grenzen aus.
Sein Motto: höher, weiter, länger -
ob blind auf dem Velo
oder beim Apnoetauchen,
der gefährlichsten und
anspruchsvollsten Art des Tauchens.
Es geht darum,
den Atem möglichst lang anzuhalten.
Nach 5 Min. 8 Sek.
taucht Steven wieder auf.
Man ist weg von allem:
von allen Gedanken, vom Alltag,
von allen Sorgen und Problemen,
und allen Wünschen,
Träumen und Zielen.
Man ist im Moment
und es gibt nichts anderes.
Das Auftauchen ist toll.
Das ist eine Gratwanderung:
Verliere ich das Bewusstsein?
Kann ich das Okay-Zeichen geben?
Packe ich es?
In den darauffolgenden Jahren
wird aus dem blinden Draufgänger
ein Medienstar.
Es folgen
unzählige Auftritte in Talkshows,
es erscheinen Filme
und Berichterstattungen über ihn.
Mittlerweile ist er 33,
hält Vorträge,
sein Leben erscheint gar in Buchform.
Steven wird zum Promi -
bis er eines Tages
dem Rampenlicht den Rücken kehrt,
die Einsamkeit sucht,
den Sinn im Glauben findet.
Hallo, Steven.
- Hoi, Roland.
Hoi. Sei willkommen.
- Danke.
Geblieben ist der Hang zum Extremen.
So wie er früher ...
... alles
aus eigener Kraft leisten wollte -
die steilsten Berge hochklettern
und die
tiefsten Brücken runterspringen ...
... will er auch Weltmeister
im Beten und Bibellesen sein.
So kam es mir vor.
Rund 15 Jahre sind seit dem
verhängnisvollen Unfall vergangen.
Mittlerweile
kann der einstige Extremsportler
den riskanten Abenteuern von früher
nur noch wenig abgewinnen.
Das Glück sucht er nun woanders.
Achtung, da hat es ein paar Äste.
Zieh den Kopf etwas ein.
Also, du. Ich nicht so.
Steven Mack
sitzt neben mir auf dieser Bank.
Wie warst du nach dem Unfall?
Was für eine Person warst du?
Eine weitersuchende.
Ich glaubte immer noch,
dass es etwas zu finden gebe.
Es war mir nicht bewusst,
dass es ein Sinneswahn war.
Es ist ja an sich eine Krankheit.
Wenn ich da runterspringe, jagt der
Körper den Puls und den Atem hoch,
und vom Instinkt her
habe ich eigentlich Todesangst.
Aber ich fand das cool und männlich,
weil man
sich dem Tod überlegen fühlt.
So:
"Ätsch, bätsch, ich hab's im Griff."
"Ich zeige, wo's durchgeht.
Ich bin unsterblich."
Hat dich die Suche nach Risiko zu
einem gewissen Grad süchtig gemacht?
Ja. Weisst du, warum?
- Nein.
Weil man nichts findet.
Man muss weitersuchen.
Darum wird man süchtig.
Sei es die Arbeit,
Sex, Alkohol, Sport, egal was ...
Ich war ganz klar
süchtig nach Adrenalin und Sport.
Ohne das fehlte etwas.
Ich ging absichtlich
an und über die Grenzen hinaus.
Ich wollte wissen, wo sie sind.
Dann die Medien,
mein Buch, die Vorträge ...
... Ansehen,
Bewunderung und Komplimente ...
Trotzdem merkte ich: "Verdammt,
das füllt mich auch nicht."
Du hast das Glück,
um das es in dieser Sendung geht,
nicht im Risiko gefunden.
Genau. Und auch nicht im Ansehen.
Ich meinte anfangs sogar,
blind zu klettern, pendeln
und Fallschirm zu springen
sei ja noch cooler.
Dass ich es dort finde.
Aber da hatte ich
meine Frau noch nicht.
Diese eine Fremde
war noch nicht gekommen.
Es kamen viele
an meinen Büchertisch.
Aber sie sagte: "Steven,
du bist auf dem falschen Weg."
Ich liess das äusserlich
nicht an mich heran.
Ich war ja stark und ein Risikomann.
Innerlich spürte ich aber,
dass sie recht hatte.
Sie spürte etwas, das ich
tief in mir drin vergraben hatte.
Wenn es draussen
Glück zu finden gab,
hatte ich das alles nach
meinen Möglichkeiten abgeklappert.
Aber sie sprach etwas an,
das ich noch nicht
anzuschauen getraut hatte:
"Vielleicht liegt es ganz woanders,
als ich bis jetzt dachte."
Das Unsichtbare -
Liebe, Ehrlichkeit, Vertrauen -
ist doch das, was wir suchen.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Aber das beizubehalten
ist nicht einfach.
Bist du immer noch versucht,
dieses Extreme irgendwie auszuloten?
Vom Sport her?
- Ja, oder auch sonst.
Ja. Es ist eine ständige Verführung,
die wir
in unserem Leben durchlaufen.
Auch hier in Lauterbrunnen:
Das ist cool.
Ich würde gerne runterspringen.
Warum nicht?
Würdest du es machen?
- Sicher.
Ich machte das auch.
Es ist ein langsames ...
... prozessartiges Ablegen
dieser Dinge.
Ich muss mich fragen,
warum ich sie machen will.
Dahinter stehen eine Bestätigung,
ein Stolz ...
... ein Sich-als-Mann-stark-fühlen,
ein Ich-kann-das.
Aber das ist so falsch.
Ich könnte auch eine Lederjacke
kaufen oder ein grosses Auto fahren.
Das ist nicht von Dauer.
Das kann dir genommen werden.
Wenn man wie du nichts sieht:
Mit was für Risiken ...
Stopp, stopp, Stopp.
- Was?- Ich sehe doch.
Was siehst du?
- Das ist immer der erste ...
... Fehleindruck:
Blinde sehen nichts.
Ich sehe nichts mit den Augen.
- Stimmt.
Aber das ist
nur etwas Visuelles, Physisches.
Aber ich glaube,
dass man eigentlich innerlich sieht.
Wenn ich morgen
sehend aufwachen würde,
wäre ich so glücklich.
Aber ich hätte Angst, dass ich
das verliere, was ich jetzt sehe.
Das wäre kaum verhinderbar.
Wenn du mich fragst,
ob ich vor den Unfall zurück und
den Weg dort weitermachen möchte,
dafür aber das bis jetzt Gewonnene
abgeben möchte,
würde ich Nein sagen.
Ich bin nicht
viel glücklicher als dazumal,
aber ich weiss, in welche Richtung
man suchen sollte.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Alles Gute auf deinem Weg.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021